so this is you Conan right now probably
the world's most famous dog I don't
think I have to use the word probably
and Conan is a incredible it's an
incredible story I learned a lot about
this particular type of dog and it's
it's train that if you open your mouth
you will be attacked you want to be very
very careful but Conan came over from
the Middle East just arrived with some
of the great people from the special
forces that did the incredible flow it
was a flawless attack and al-baghdadi is
gone but that was a flawless attack and
I just met quite a few of them and we
just gave Conan a a medal and a plaque
and it's really and I actually think
Conan knew exactly what was going on but
a dog that is very very special and we
could maybe say you want to say
something about
you're going to put a muzzle on the dog
and I thought that was a good idea but
then it gets even more violent John so I
had a choice but now the dog is
incredible actually incredible we spent
some good time with it and so brilliant
so smart the way it was with the special
forces people that have worked with and
for obvious reasons they can't be out in
front of the media but they did a
fantastic job Conan did a fantastic job
and we're very honored to have Conan
here and to have given Conan a
certificate and an award that we're
going to put up in the White House
Michael you have something to say it's
great to be here mr. president I know
you just finished the meeting with some
of the very same Special Forces who
completed a successful raid that took
down the leader of Isis but I recall mr.
president when you made the decision
right up there in the White House the
day before the raid you had talked about
measures that were available to protect
our soldiers and it had been described
to us about the fact that they had dogs
that could go in in the event that al
Baghdadi had on him a explosive vest
that you put the premium on the safety
of our Special Forces and this dog was
there suffered some injury we were able
to complete the raid without any
American casualty and so I think having
the Special Forces here today who
obviously can't come out in the public
but also having this extraordinary dog
here today is all a reflection of of our
armed forces a great job that they do
Coenen is really a hero it's really it's
a real joy to be able to help welcome
her here at the White House Conan was
very badly hurt
as you know and they thought maybe was
not going to recover recovered actually
very quickly and has since gone on very
important raise as you know we captured
100 percent of the Isis Caliphate when I
took office we had almost nothing it was
as though they were just forming again
and now it's a hundred percent and we
have done a lot of work since then we
have done a lot of work since the rain
certain things have happened that are
very important so we're very good shape
we're very good shape we've had a lot of
help too from other countries we've had
we've really done a job I just want to
thank you all so this is a special time
for Conan and we really appreciated it I
was told about at the breed I was told
about coating himself and Conan is a
tough cookie
and nobody's gonna mess with Don and I
asked one question I said so what chance
with Conan I got to see how fast
Conan can move I said what chance would
a strong man have really strong tough
fighter what chance would this person
tap against Conan without the guns
what chance and I guess the answer
pretty much was none he would have no
chance so it's amazing and yet you see
how beautiful and how calm during a
situation like this is and you're very
lucky to visit he's not in a bad mood
today
yep not a bad mood you're saying anyway
so I want to thank you all thank you
very much and it's a great honor to have
Conan here a great honor to have the
special forces here there
no coders are retiring yet
Conan's primetime age-wise fronting I
asked that question they go for about
six years like an athlete six years they
start they'd like to get them at one and
a half or two years old and they'll go
for about six years from that time after
that it happens where maybe the reflexes
aren't quite as good you know things
like that happen would never happen to
us but the door prime time it is those
six years after - and they're very
special dogs are very hard to get this
particular dog is this is the Ultimate
Fighter ultimate everything ultimate in
terms of sniffing drugs we have we spent
a tremendous amount of money on drug
equipment that the boater and I've
spoken to the people I say well is there
anything better than this equipment no
sir the only thing better is a dog a dog
this type of dog exactly because it's a
certain type of dog and it's pretty
amazing but they are really better we
had a case where we had drugs in a
cylinder of a car and it was
undetectable by this very expensive
machine which is really amazing
machinery but still it was undetectable
the dog came in wah jumped in the hood
pointing you know opened the hood and
knew exactly it's incredible the sense
of smell or whatever it may be probably
sense of smell so they're incredible
animals and thank you all very much
you